we are going to begin with one of the
nation's most politically influential
social media platforms now under new
ownership could have big implications
for our democracy according to multiple
reports Elon Musk is now officially in
charge of Twitter after a
multi-billion dollar deal that he
actually tried to back out of at one
point there are also reports that he's
already fired the CEO and other top
Executives change is coming there
overnight musk tweeted quote the bird is
freed Jonathan Vigliotti has made his
way to Twitter headquarters in San
Francisco Jonathan yesterday Mr musk
walked in with a sink apparently
executives are walking out with little
boxes of their stuff and she's coming
good morning
uh good morning to you Tony and the
question this morning how will musk
balance out freedom of speech well at
the same time discouraging and reigning
in misinformation the stakes are
incredibly high for millions of
Americans I want you to keep in mind the
U.S prosecutors determined in 2016 a
Russian agency used Twitter and other
social media sites in an attempt to sway
the election even Twitter's founder said
misinformation about false election
claims led to the attack on the capitol
last year
you made an offer to buy Twitter
billionaire entrepreneur Elon Musk has
been talking and tweeting about it since
April well I think it's very important
for
uh there to be an inclusive arena for
free speech
after roaring onto the roads with Tesla
well welcome and soaring into the Galaxy
with SpaceX musk has now apparently
taken over the twitterverse in a deal
valued at 44 billion dollars I think
he's clear that it's gonna he's gonna
take it in a different direction Brent
Phil is a technology Analyst at
Jeffrey's he says the immediate firings
of top Executives as reported by the
Associated Press would be part of those
changes he was clear that uh he didn't
align with the board or the senior
management team and he believed the
company was poorly run added to that
musk has been vocal about the role he
wants to see the social media giant play
in Global Communications he tweeted a
message to advertisers Thursday saying
in part the reason I acquired Twitter is
because it is important to the future of
civilization to have a common digital
Town Square voicing concerned that
traditional media has fueled and catered
to polarized extremes and in doing so
the opportunity for dialogue is lost he
added Twitter obviously cannot become a
free-for-all hellscape where anything
could be said with no consequences but
Phil wonders if musk's business model
where even controversial voices are
welcome will work in the short term the
only way the Financial Health continues
is advertising and I can tell you every
Advertiser I speak to is running from
this platform not flocking to the
platform
and when we talk about the threat of
misinformation there will be a critical
test in the weeks to come when millions
of American voters head to the polls for
the midterms donate but their voices
yeah people will be watching out for
misinformation and the like but to the
earlier Point uh you reported that Elon
Musk says he doesn't want a free-for-all
hellscape his words uh where anything
can be said no consequences on Twitter
uh I think the question on a lot of
people's minds is what does that mean
for folks who have been banned or
suspended people like I don't know
Donald Trump Kanye West
[Music]
um
yeah a great question Tony at this point
we can only speculate at what musk
himself has said publicly back in may he
said he would reverse a ban on Trump his
quote saying morally wrong flat out
stupid to have such a ban at this hour
we can say right now Trump is still
suspended of course all of that could
change and rapidly we've seen a lot of
Rapid decisions in just a few hours once
Twitter was taken over by him
he's the chief twit now as he puts it
Jonathan thank you very much some people
say just get your popcorn and let's go